we do not descend because we are wolf
herds of fighter you touch to one and you touch
I like to dance to evolve
wake up spilling my poetry on a
rebel instrumental perennial same seasoning
women
Guatemala is a country with one of the
higher rates of femicide than there are in
the world and also with a few rates of
intrafamily violence and violence
aggravate a lot very strong too
which is idiolect towards structures
anachronistic I'm not anonymous I'm
feminist anarchist pirate in your
horns hears media that long ago the
submissive costume went flying with the
wind being a woman in guatemala is difficult
in every way and here since
go out to the street stop not for the
people who are throwing a shot
that really is street harassment about
of how you see yourself making the committee of
this enemy here I am more route than
you have to shoot every night under
Chaco and pure xibalbá
this is obsidian poetry how are you
songs help so many people now
to get ahead inspires me a lot
to stay connected with the energy of the
love and with the energy of healing today
I want to sing incoherent this
postmodern of eternal spring not
live from the video but really not
I wanted to get lost in time and he told me
that is not the one that breaks